Elon Musk was interviewed by Tucker
Carlson and the interview goes horribly
wrong now I have to tell you that there
is an irony
to
the contingent that has become the
strongest Defenders of Elon Musk and I'm
going to explain why in a moment but one
of the most notable things about this
interview billed as a two-night special
night one was last night night two is
tonight so if you just couldn't get
enough last night there will be more of
this tonight much of the interview was
spent by Tucker Carlson just sucking up
to Elon Musk and you do get the sense
you know Tucker in those Dominion voting
systems texts exposed as hating Trump
passionately you get the feeling that
Tucker is really desperate for Elon to
like him and much of what that includes
is Tucker doing the maniacal laughter
when Elon tells pretty mediocre jokes uh
check this out how
you funded it at the beginning what
happened yeah well that would be ironic
if it's the most ironic outcome is most
likely it seems
um
that's good that's actually referring to
my Jonah I came up with that one I
actually have a slight variant on that
which is the most entertaining outcome
is the most likely but that's
entertaining as viewed from a third
party viewer
hi uh so this this was a lot of the
interview it really was and we're going
to get to more substantive things but I
I later in the interview I tuned back in
and Tucker is still sucking up to Elon
Musk there are times of their of their
badge this morning and then you called
them diarrhea okay you did you did I'm
just I'm just quoting you you described
it
I said this is the Twitter code Twitter
colons of diary okay it's not literally
diarrhea but no it's uh you know it's a
metaphor um
hey okay so very entertaining to Tucker
as you can see and it's all great and
very very exciting eventually the
subject matter did turn to Twitter now
Twitter by any objective measure I hate
to go back into toilet humor but it's
been flushed significantly since Elon
Musk took over
um advertisers fleeing Twitter
engagement down this disastrous for you
feed that promotes mostly right-wing
nonsense Twitter blue where you can pay
to be verified and that went completely
backwards it's been very bad and
arguably uh based on not even arguably
based on the belief that Elon Musk was
trying to raise money at a 20 million
dollar valuation you can make the
argument that Twitter's value has
declined by more than 50 since Elon Elon
Musk purchased it okay so here Elon Musk
says he's sort of in The Matrix because
he's been heavily on Twitter since 2009.
since I've been a heavy Twitter user
since 2009
um
my it's it's sort of like I'm in The
Matrix I mean I can see like things do
things feel right do they not feel right
what what tweets am I being shown as
recommended uh
like I get a feel like what accounts are
making comments uh where are the
comments uh eerily similar yeah
um and uh he's really he's really
managing by feel which is interesting
given that these are the facts don't
care about your feelings people you look
at the account and it's just obviously a
fake photo and uh you know uh that it's
just obviously a bot cluster uh over and
over again so I started to get like just
more and more uneasy about the the
Twitter situation yeah he was uneasy and
as you can see here from Tucker's
expression Tucker is very concerned you
can tell from Tucker's expression that
he's very very concerned about this the
topic of Twitter's role in upcoming
elections did come up and Elon Musk says
that not only in domestic elections but
even internationally Twitter is going to
play a major role I'm just saying but
you're kind of exposed in your other
businesses so this is just in case
reviews aren't following this
this is not you're not just like a
journalist taking a stand on behalf of
the First Amendment you're a guy with
big government contracts giving the
finger to the government do you think
um
Twitter will be as Central to this
presidential campaign as it wasn't the
last several I think it will play a
significant role in elections not just
domestically but internationally the
goal of new Twitter is to be
um as fair and even-handed as possible
by the way doesn't new Twitter sort of
remind every anybody else of New Coke
this was a disaster corporate disaster
where Coca-Cola
had a new Coke and I've read about it in
so many business case studies I don't
remember what the differences were how
it was flavored or sweetened or was it
the Colorado then there was like Clear
Pepsi
all new Twitter it's you're calling it
something but really it's just sort of
like bad twitter so not favoring any
political
ideology which is hard to believe given
that the for you feed is almost
exclusively right-wing propaganda uh
just um
yeah being being fair at all yeah the
topic then turned to artificial
intelligence an interesting topic and I
actually do think Elon Musk has we
finally have gotten to something where I
think Elon Musk has interesting things
to say let's listen to what he said
about AI although it's a little bit uh a
little bit woo-woo it is fundamentally
profound in that the
the smartest creatures as far as you
know on this Earth are humans
um is our defining characteristic yes um
we're obviously uh weaker than say
chimpanzees are less agile
um but real smarter
so
uh now what happens when something
uh vastly smarter than the smartest
person comes along in Silicon foam right
that's pretty scary at least as far as
Elon Musk wants you to be concerned so
his idea is to create rather than chat
GPT
truth GPT truth essential not truth not
truth truth GPT
we're going to start something which you
call truth gbt or a maximum truth
seeking AI that tries to understand the
nature of the universe and I think this
this might be the best path to Safety in
the sense that an AI that cares about
understanding the universe uh it is
unlikely to annihilate humans because we
are an interesting part of the universe
there you go now this stuff is actually
sort of interesting the the the problem
with the entire interview is obviously
the sort of Hero's welcome that Elon
Musk is getting from people like Tucker
Carlson despite the fact that listen I I
don't I don't take the side that Elon
Musk is some extreme right-wing nut
who is aligned with the hardcore Maga
right on every issue in fact the truth
is very different and it's interesting
to see how many of the people now
defending Elon Musk and sort of
fanboying out around him hate electric
cars and Elon Musk of course owns Tesla
think space exploration is a really
stupid waste of money and Elon Musk has
SpaceX like it's not lost on me that
Elon Musk is actually involved in a lot
of really interesting companies that are
antithetical to what many on the right
want I've also said that I'm a long time
I I used to own Tesla stock for years
and years although I've gotten out of it
now and I'm a long time Tesla driver
although I do plan to go in a different
direction when my current lease is up
for reasons I've explained that have
nothing to do with Elon Musk
specifically so I don't have this kind
of black white view of Elon Musk the
real issue with musk right now
is that
through whatever series of events is it
kind of cozying up to Joe Rogan and
Texas Republicans like Greg Abbott and
just kind of being in that environment
and this has shifted his view or based
on who is signal boosting him on Twitter
he's sort of like become uh adjacent to
some horrible right-wing people for
whatever reason he's getting the hero's
welcome from the right at this point in
time and he is expressing
some pretty horrifying views including
like everybody should vote for
republicans in the midterms and all
these different things but the irony
isn't lost on me that he also does stand
for at least as far as many of his
businesses go things that the right
actually hates and yet they love them
because of the heroes welcome that
right-wing media has decided that he
should get so that was only night one of
this Blockbuster interview with Tucker
Carlson Knight 2 will be tonight if
there's anything interesting I'll have
it for you tomorrow
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than this
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor sure to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below